Pra Pra Pra!
Hey, how's it goin? What's up?
Best let's play on YouTube. Let's go.
Thank you very much, we just-
Huddle up, it's selfie time everybody.
I thought something would actually happen me coming back here, but nothing happened at all
Oh no.
All right
What?
Find 10 yaoi in South Park?
I only found like three of them
Are you kidding me?
That can't be my quest I'm leaving.
There's no way
There's no way that's my quest
Sergeant please!
I changed my mind
Are you serious? That's my job right now?
To found Yaoi.
That is the-
Talk to Mr. Adams in the police...
...station
It seems like we've done all the main quest?
Whaat?
I don't want to do Yaoi. I don't find Yaoi. I'm not gay.
Wow Felix
Can't believe you just said that
All right supposedly, there's a quest in here, so we might as well take it.
Just let me in, let me in.
It's supposed to be aaaaaa weird-looking-
There he is
EEEEW!
Okay, let's talk things out.
Oh my god.
The quests are so weird.
Distribute Mr. Adams headshots to eight people?
Okay.
That shouln't be too hard.
Or do we got it wait, sorry, I'm
That's our quest how do I do hundred more like you on the force?
Crime doesn't pay kid you're on our team now, right I?
Have to say I'm ugly impressed with your making oh
Okay, I was so lost I was like there's no main quest going on right now
There we go we got gotta go to Coon lair
I don't think it's too far we can go there
Scrambles screwed franchise
Franchise
Scrambles screwed
franchise screwed scrambles
Good
Wait there's a new code get scrambles fast
Well what about introducing super Craig in the second Kooning fringe movie that'd be pretty DC comics of us, I wouldn't recommend it
Please have a seat. Sorry guys. Can I have a moment with but lord please?
Wait I'm but Lauren behind you
Okay, let's talk to Kuhn see what it's got to sing everybody
but Lord
I just wanted to let you know that we've decided
To let you have your own Netflix series right after the Fast Pass Fox miniseries and the third Coon and friends United
Nations, this is huge
Okay, well get out there and finish your girls. Just wanted to tell you the exciting news
What do you want new kid you do, there's nothing left to talk about oh
No, no no, no you are not going to have yes come on three choices new kid
No
Do not give me those sad puppy eyes
nobody gets to be three classes it you think that just because you had to live through your dad fucking your mom you should get
All the sympathy in the world don't you?
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to bring that it
If you were going to add another class what would it be oh
Hell yeah, we need another class cuz
Blaster cyborg it was terrible. Okay. We got a close range, okay?
We definitely don't want elementalist
late night in f1 has grinding power to fortified teammates and
disability I
Think we have no psychic on it shut up
Whatever I came to sign
It is pretty dumb. Let's go back in time again back to when you were just a child
You couldn't sleep that night, but it was because you saw strange lights in the sky you walk to the mirror oh
Man, I'm excited for this, but these are so dumb. I love it. Oh yeah then
You heard it strange alien sounds from the hallway. Oh my god. You walked out into intruders
An alien my god, all right, we're an element in it
Okay, what is this?
That's pretty shit
What does that do though
That's awesome that's really good. Oh, no I can't
St.. Rip, let's go nice
Oh
You think right impossible moussaka
Yeah, I don't know if I want to do that well, I got to go here to do it
Oh dolphins Wow which gives me attack
I think I'm over here. We got a halt ready
Bailey doesn't even do anything
Aah Oh Mac yeah
Wow that was so cool
Does that skip all their turns, and oh nice
He's gonna die and same with him
Nice
Okay, okay, okay, let's start again didn't they know
Where the aliens helping you by showing you who fucked your mom or were they trying to make you full of rage you might never
know
all right get back out there, but Lord you still have a lot of things to do I
Don't think that was worth the three classes that backstory, but you know what I will take it
I will take it and I will shove it up my butt about but
Man, I remember some of the stuff that happened in the first game now that when you were abducted by the aliens
Oh my god. That was like too much, and when you become a little mushy you whatever you minimize yourself. That was crazy
Okay, it sounds like we got to go to the
We got a walk-in, are you kidding me?
Okay, let's go to the playground I
Thought looking guys we're now at style in the eighties, but the new kids pulling it up
Here we are at the playground nice
How did the Coon get there so fast
I didn't come to fight
This
Visionary architect and a buttfucking trader listen to me. I understand the new kid oh
No my god
Where haven't seen him
You might be in the wrong franchise, but if you ever need help. I'll return the favor you might be in their own franchise
Cares about you. You belong to a loser zero income franchise that's run by a douchebag in a wheelchair
You steal it. Where is dr. Timothy's phone, sorry freedom pussy that info?
You guys need to stop investigating the Chamber of Commerce and leave it to the professionals superheroes
Oh, yeah, you guys are the professional superheroes. Yeah, it just so happens mysterion that we already have a connection with Netflix
No, you don't yes. We do. We're just about to get the human kite and Netflix series off the ground so
No
Timmy he's trying to rape my mind
They don't have a connection Netflix freedom pouch just raped my mind you guys let's get these pedophile who did friends
It's simple freedom pals unite never want to go again
Simple white tears going down. Hello share should have made changes. God. Damn it I
Didn't make changes today
All right, that's fine alright goes pray I feel pretty good about my lineup. They really are far away aren't thing
It's not really worth it
I'm just gonna place him here
That's a microaggression right there oh
Oh, this is awesome look at this we can suck
Suck him over here, and then keep doing damage on him
Oh
My god, what is he doing? He's telephoning in fourth-graders?
Second brannis preschool kids whatever. They are my god. They're everywhere
Come on captain diabeetus come up come on
Thank you, oh my god. I'm so glad he's dead
Wait that isn't kill the little kids. Are you kidding me? I need some kids to die oh
They die super fast now. Okay, alright. Let's kill kill the children
Damn that does a lot of damage come here. We go finally my god those so difficult. Oh
I'm so done with that
Jesus
It took me 40 minutes at least
And if you ever want to be part of a real franchise just call me
Marvelous better
Hey
Wait sorry there's boys girls and sissy
Go to crunchies microbrew for some microaggression knowledge, I can't wait this is great stuff
It doesn't get better than this guys
And here we are
Going to get some info on
The macro grass on
This out-of-control Men Pacific icelandic islander from
Scandinavia
Now I get to change my skin colour tone, I identify as white
And white now what the heck
See that wasn't hard was it now that you know how to define yourself
you can go back to making people pay for not identifying you and others correctly a
Little more about you kid now get out there kick some ass gosh darn it
I don't think what is this good example for the young folks?
Fine
We have the information we need and are ready for our next mission everyone reports there immediately
Another Coon lair mission, huh
And
Scrambles hmm
Lucky tiger there you are Jesus took you long enough, sorry
My bad
All right everyone
But Lord interrogated classy and found out our next lead is that the you store in here in town we need to infiltrate it tonight
That can't be done. Why not just you know because they use door and entrances all lava. Oh, yeah
To do with anything
It's one of his superpowers hey and to shed said that he owes the new kid a favor oh
My god looks like you're gonna come in handy again
My lord super Craig right you're not on the team out of the toolshed
Tell the new kid is ready to have his favor returned everyone else go home and get in bed
We meet at the you store in tonight
Too bad
If all goes according to plan toolshed will meet up with you later, just be careful toolshed is a two-faced backstabbing butt sniffer hmm, ah
sure
Don't know why this is the thing but you know we got to go back gotta go back home to sleep
This is that we look like huh?
pretty shit
All right, it's time to eat dinner and be old depressing shit cuz our parents our
Dad had sex with our mom can you believe it?
No meaning it and an alien showed it to us along with the baby
my god
We live a tough life
We changed
What is this story news
First asking the counselor about sexual orientation, then talking to the principal about race
Confusion was the point the more our child learns about the truth the more dangerous it becomes you stupid Oh
On the table pumpkin then straight to bed you have school tomorrow
There's the underlying plot and a plot chest twist waiting to happen but for now
Let's go to sleep. Oh
Nice, we got a lot of cloth. We can make a new outfit listen
I know we never talked about it, but your mother and I are very proud
I
Know we never talked about it, but we're so proud to be Scandinavia
Wish I kept the skin color corruption and crime rises from the gutters and fills the streets only one thing to deal
Man hashtag yes, I agree let's go
Browse it's time to change
But this is not really our outfit is it?
We're gonna we're gonna change our outfit
Cuz I want to look we got a lot of new stuff actually we have whoa what in the world is this?
We can also craft I believe
We could probably craft some costumes
They are SH NEX is pretty cool. The boom boxes. Oh, that's dope
We can actually make that what else did we got amazing butthole hood
And then we had the Norse oh
This is all very tempting stuff, but I do
Okay
Okay, let's see how this looks this is important stuff guys. I don't know if you realize
Wait where is it there it is nice since we look so goddamn stupid, that's the issue here
Yes
Now we're talking yeah, I'm too Pumbaa excited, but sorry
I can't stand I can't stand that stupid facial hair. It's so annoying
Okay
We're gonna find the keys again to escape
What the heck is our dad doing of course we gotta use their
Hoss feature to get the key
All right, and we're gonna teleport back anyways
The power of farts everyone
the power of farts
They sure love fart jokes in this
and this franchise I
Guess another key, and that's it I think
No, we need the copper key as well
Where in the world is?
the copper key
They really barrack here today. Well huh they don't want us to go in out copper key, maybe in the kitchen yes
Now let's go Braves
What in the world man what's going on there is
Indeed we do
And it needs to it needs to
Father was in the garage working on a project. Okay huge storm and lightning blue my father off his workbench
I ran to help him, but at that moment another blast somehow
Fused his power tools onto my body I became a superhero while my father was left mentally impaired. Well. He sure is mentally impaired
Right now and stop keying my car, okay
What's wrong with Hanuman?
This is different my father's acting even stupider than ever before
Perhaps toolshed wants to help his father because he feels he could have saved him all those years ago perhaps
So I have to do this oh they come jr.. Yeah, oh
I never we never been here
Oh, yes it did it something horrible, I don't even want to talk about it
That's okay. You don't talk about it. It must be very painful. It is indeed
extremely painful makes your story seem like a
child's goodnight story
Anyway, let's enter you see there's lava here. I need your help
He has a shortcut to the north of town I mean that's a lot of Lego regardless, right?
Damn
Be careful, but held you're dealing with a bad fucking trader who would but
I'm talking about - shit - she's a big asshole traded. Don't let him trick you dude. Can you let it lay off?
He's helping answer oh
We're in Kenny's house yeah, oh my god, I can't seem to walk right with this character
We got some more client Oh tweaking Craig fan art
Yowee collector Danny, what is going on here?
With the pores it generates it can clear nearly any obstacle, okay show me
It looks like there's still lava there, but okay a
Secret tunnel huh ma'am our look homeless people we were probably gonna find him
Fuck I wanted to attack them first, but whatever we can kill me
Only so many tool base one-liners in the world you know
Yeah, there you go that was good no, no that was good
That's my double screw it Pierce's in both directions huh that was very neat buddy very nice body
Somebody's about to get fixed who's it gonna be?
There it is
Nice
Very nice. Oh yes, that's how it's done. Oh
Mom mom aren't you glad you're watching this huh best best doesn't get back?
It couldn't be better actually let me adjust my artifacts while you shut up. Okay, shut up I
Still have these shitty ones
Okay well, let's keep going
All right
Where are you taking me hmm through here more lava. Yeah, yeah, oh my god, it's
Those guys should stay on the
New kid what fine?
As long as there's a power generator nearby I can use my dad's sand blaster to clear almost any obstacle wow that is good
Wow that is indeed fantastic Coon and friends
After tonight were sworn enemies again
Fine there's damn cats I forgot that was supplied because I'm so invested in
Saving this cat I want nothing more in my life than to save this damn game. Thank you
Hey, there's a key there
Let's try that
Right that calendar. Oh my god. It's beautiful look at that candle in there for a second
Okay, what else do we got in here main is the same?
That was a bit too easy wasn't it
Shit we have a really cool costume though right like we don't need to
That is pretty dope
Ours is cooler. Okay? I know what's cool guys
Trust me. I know it's cool. I'm wearing a cap backwards alright. It doesn't get cooler than that alright. What are you wearing then? Huh?
But you're wearing underwears on your face
too dummy
That is indeed what is this? Oh my god? We're left in it's a trap
It's a trap everybody
Emitted fuck French
Hams are so cute. Oh my god. Yes. No. Don't let me kill them. That is a lot of hamsters. I'm a cat
We're surrounded this is Dan
Let's keep going through whoa this is dope I love what you've done with the place. Oh my god
This is dope oh, yeah, we need a
Captain diabeetus penis, right
Let's need to get here
Damn his face ah I never get comfortable - this
Will go back in time so we can keep going
Now we didn't forget
Where's the stupid cat can't it's locked oh, there's something here oh
My god, what is the Oh?
Its actual minions is that all those hooks are ten fall on them
Okay this should be a cake in the Tate Timberlake
They have CDs on them damn those dogs are from the future
Nice just the dog left
It was
What
Are they Mexican oh look at that
It's cute
These babe when dinero oh I missed one and
It's gone down
Dick King
Sorry Mexicans, I'm sorry if you're Mexican and watching this just know that I don't condone with this horrible
Prejudiced bad thing think
Ok alright ok now we can go in here of course of course the dam can't better be in here is all I'm seen
Oh, I forgot the pause you're a dead
Power fart pouch it's a very good ability. You can go through and hit the switch
Very nice. Oh look how many weapons
Do we need these
What what do you used to get past there oh I see I see I see
No my bed
Of course I got to move on fire, so I'm so dumb
Come here dynamite. Did you know that dynamite is a Swedish invention? You're welcome well
You're welcome, and it was discovered by accident
Err. It is very nice
Where's the bleeding cat okay, let's get Kyle's
Fart scoring Tim
So dumb I can't even yeah
All right, let's keep going on a night event I'd avenge your bed a very rare shut up wait sorry how?
How do I get them?
What oh
My go my god, shut up, man, you don't know me there's something here
Yes, of course
Genius I'm a genius man. Oh my god
Hey look at that
Okay, I'm not gonna go back at camp it, but there. That's too far to walk
Nice let's take all day, I got a feeling there's a strong bass incoming
There's no tool there hmm can we go here?
super Craig
Yes, we do fuck it dad
Call girl
The owner is a part of a new crime syndicate oh
Fuck it's that cold. Yeah. Well. She's not in the Union excuse me
Are you on Instagram someone new in town who's bringing all the crime families together, okay? Cool. Thank you back
You mean like a kingpin you guys do not say anything?
Tough not playing with her check out storage facility 50 60 new kids in here take this
Call me if you need me I think you're gonna need all the help you can get
So I guess now any fuckin asshole thinks they can be a superhero well pretty much just find scrambles and be done
All righty then
We're gonna end that episode there
Hope you enjoyed it really appreciate a like and comment whatever all the support has been amazing really appreciate you guys
It's still fun to play this for you, and it's a fun thing for everyday
And I hope you're enjoying the ride as well as see you tomorrow. Good day back